foreign
welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
in today's video we are going to be
talking about YouTube ads we'll share
with you what they are what type of
YouTube ads are available how do you
create them what are the benefits you
can get with them so there's a lot to
cover in this topic of YouTube ads but
before that I am Mark campman I am your
digital navigator for this video and as
usual if you liked the video click the
like button and if you want to join our
Channel click the Subscribe button that
you can find under this video but before
we go into the topic of YouTube ads let
me share with you a new program that
simply learn has put together together
with Purdue University marketing land
search engine journal and yes meta as
well and the good thing about this
course is that you will get all the
skills in digital marketing to easily
complete the meta blueprint courses as
well which are very high standard
courses on everything you want to know
about Facebook and Facebook advertising
so I can highly recommend this course
and just follow the link and the link
will be in the um in the notes below the
video as well so don't hesitate but join
this video right enough about this let's
go straight into
um YouTube advertising now let me give
you some history to begin with in 2007
YouTube introduced the ability for
creators to monetize their videos with
ads
yes so welcome back to that later there
are three players in YouTube advertising
there is the YouTube creators there are
the brands and there is Google itself of
course well the good thing about YouTube
ads that is brands are able to reach an
audience and video creators in YouTube
they are able to monetize their their
videos by enabling Brands to place ads
before or during these videos initially
these ads were displayed as overlays on
top of videos or as a pre-roll ad before
the video played now in 2010 YouTube
introduced trueview ads they allowed
viewers to skip ads after five seconds
and only charged advertisers if viewers
watched at least 30 seconds of the ad so
that was a benefit for
um for the viewer they could skip the ad
but also a Ben benefit for the brands
because the people that watch the whole
ad were more likely to engage with the
brand now in 2015 there was a new
introduction from YouTube which was the
six second bumper ads very short fleshy
ads that you can run during during
videos in 2016 YouTube faced controversy
yeah when ads
appeared on extremist and controversial
videos yeah so that led to many videos
pulling their ads and YouTube really had
to get their act together so YouTube
implemented stricter ad policies and
introduced new ad formats such as
sponsored cards and mid-roll ads in 2018
YouTube introduced the non-skippable ads
for viewers on desktop devices so you
could not skip the ad in 2019 YouTube
introduced at pods so you could do two
back-to-back ads before a video starts
and they can be skipped after five
seconds as well now today YouTube offers
a variety of AD formats for advertisers
including display ads overlay ads
sponsored cards skippable non-scapable
video ads bumper ads and mid-roll ads
and we're gonna cover these later in
this video
all right so let's move on let's talk
about what we're going to discuss in
this video we're going to start with
giving you a short introduction to
YouTube ads yeah what is it where how
can you use it but then look at the
benefits of using YouTube ads and then
of course you want to know what are the
different types of YouTube ads that I
can use and I'm going to share with you
the library of ads that Google has and
which ads you would want to use in what
particular circumstance circumstance now
a very big benefit of YouTube ads is the
targeting that you can do with the ads
so we'll cover the YouTube ads targeting
and then I'm just going to go into
Google ads with you and show you how to
create a YouTube ad and you will see
that it's a very simple thing to do and
then finally we'll close the session
with some tips and tricks on YouTube ads
and that should be it for Google and the
YouTube ads so let's dive straight into
this let me give you a short
introduction to YouTube ads to begin
with so let's talk about video
and advertising with videos video
advertising refers to the use of videos
to promote a product a service or a
brand it's very straightforward video
ads can be displayed on various
platforms like desktop on TV on social
media on websites and it can take
different forms yes so it can be a
pre-roll ad it can be a mid-roll ad and
it can be sponsored content that you can
see on the website video ads are very
very powerful because they are more
engaging and more memorable than any
other type of ads people prefer to watch
things and what they see they will
remember they can convey emotion they
can convey storytelling and visual
appeal making them more compelling than
traditional ads you can also reach a
much wider audience and it can be easily
shared across social media so it
increases your reach and it increases
your brand awareness
now one of the issues with advertising
on desktops is that a lot of people have
ad banners of ad blockers installed on
their desktop and that is a and that
Limits The Reach of General advertising
on desktop and also limits to reach of
your advertising on YouTube
because if I have an ad blocker
installed I won't see any ads on YouTube
now there's different ways of getting
um getting about that yes so try to work
with your um your audience that they
um that they don't use an ad blocker to
have access to your radio content but
the reality is that the best platform
for advertising
um is on there for video is on mobile
yeah mobile devices they have they have
fewer ad blockers and you will reach
more people bear in mind that probably
70 80 percent of people watch videos on
YouTube on their mobile anyway yeah so
mobile devices they're becoming
increasingly popular for video
consumptions video consumption more
people watching videos on their
smartphone therefore a much better area
much better channel for you to advertise
yeah so they can be much more in
effective on mobile to capture users
attention and to generate engagement
because mobiles are more personal and
they're more intimate than other devices
so mobile video ads are more cost
effective you can Target specific
audiences and you can optimize them for
the different mobile devices so
all in all
mobile ads very powerful desktop ads
still a very good medium to use for your
video advertising now let's go to then
to the next level and let's talk about
YouTube ads
so YouTube ads are a form of video
advertising displayed on Google's
YouTube platform
yes so advertisers they can create and
upload videos yeah to be displayed but
then they can turn them into ads that
they can be displayed before during
after YouTube videos or a standalone ads
and they can take different forms as I
mentioned earlier they can be pre-roll
mid-roll display ads sponsored cards
bumper ads and what helps you and the
big advantage of YouTube advertising you
can Target very specific audiences based
on demographics interests behaviors and
a lot more and we'll cover that in a
later section of this presentation so it
can be a very powerful tool for brand
awareness for generating leads and for
driving sales so let's dive a little bit
deeper into this targeting is one of the
most effective
features in YouTube ads yeah so there's
lots of ways that you can Target people
in in YouTube advertising you can do
demographic targeting so targeting based
on age gender parental status household
income you can do interest targeting
targeting based on your users interests
and habits on and off YouTube you could
do behavioral targeting based on a
user's past behavior and interactions
with ads and content you can also do the
remarketing where you can Target people
who have interacted with your website or
with previous ads
you can do custom intent targeting like
targeting users based on keywords and
phrases that they have used when they
searched on Google and YouTube
you can do placement targeting where you
can very sort of specify which channels
videos or types of content you want to
use you can do topic targeting yep so
you can Target videos and channels
related to the specific topics or
categories of your business you can
Target by location
and you can also Target by device so
this again is one of the biggest
benefits that you can get in using
YouTube advertising
another feature is that YouTube ads are
part of Google ads yeah and that is
Google's advertising platform that
allows you to create and display ads on
various Google properties including
YouTube including Google search Google
Maps Google Display Network you can do
shopping ads so it is a fully blown
advertising platform and YouTube ads is
just part of that so it's the same
interface so if you're used to using
Google ads for creating search ads or
display ads and I'll show you later
YouTube ads is just another feature of
that functionality you can even use the
same Google ads account to create and
manage your YouTube ads and you can set
the same targeting options you can use
the same audiences that you created and
you can use the same reporting tools so
very easy very simple to set up and it
makes it very easy for advertisers to
run and to track their campaigns across
multiple platforms
YouTube analytics is another tool that
provides data and insights on the
performance of your YouTube videos and
your YouTube channel and those insights
are very very powerful you can track
metrics like views watch time engagement
audience demographics and it provides
information on traffic sources Revenue
generation if you've activated that and
even audience retention how long will
people watch the video and when do they
drop off and you can learn a lot about
it on fine-tuning your your content so
YouTube analytics YouTube insights can
be used to analyze the effectiveness of
your YouTube ads you can check use it to
monitor your growth of your channel and
to optimize your videos and it can be
accessed through the same analytics
dashboards and the first time YouTube
Studio dashboard and you can customize
and filter the data to get more specific
insights
right so then also you need to
understand the kind of the ecosystem for
YouTube advertising there are three
players as I mentioned at the beginning
of the video there are three players
that are involved in the YouTube
advertising there is the content
creators or the video creators there are
the brands and there is YouTube or
Google
and all three would like to make money
and the beauty is that Google and
YouTube they put together an
infrastructure that allows Brands to
make money and that allows YouTube video
creators to make money
so video creators they have their videos
on YouTube and they have their Channel
and when you
qualify and meet certain
conditions like number of followers or
subscribers to your channel a number of
hours that people have watched your
videos you can qualify
for the advertising sort of partnership
yep and then when you qualified for that
you or Google will add you to the video
Network that Brands can use to place
their ads
yes so there is a money making
opportunity for video creators
brands have another objective they want
to reach as big an audience as possible
yeah and that's the beauty of YouTube
there are so many people using YouTube
so many people watching videos on
YouTube it is a fantastic platform to
show their ads on the content before or
during the videos from the YouTube video
creators
yes so the YouTube video creators can't
live without a branch to make money the
brands can't live without the YouTube
video creators to actually reach their
advertising objectives and then Google
YouTube is the third party managing this
ecosystem as it were and Google YouTube
is always sort of doing the The
Balancing Act of keeping both the video
creators and the brands happy
yeah so keep that in mind
advertisers video creators and YouTube
the three key players in um in YouTube
so what are the benefits then of using
YouTube ads well let's look at some
numbers the main benefit of YouTube
advertising lies in the size of YouTube
has over 2 billion monthly active users
and it's the second most visited website
in the world
over 1 billion hours of videos are
watched on YouTube every day which is
equivalent to over 114
000 years of video
now the most viewed video on YouTube by
the way is baby shark Dance by pinkfong
with over 9.5 billion views as of
February 2023 and the highest paid
YouTube earner
yes so in 2021 was a nine-year-old kid
named Ryan Kaji who earned almost 30
million dollars from his YouTube channel
Ryan's world
so not only of course there's part the
advertising partly sponsorships yeah so
there's lots of other ways to monetize
your channel as well so YouTube is a
channel that is out there and it is a
and a fantastic channel to get a huge
reach for your campaign now let's take a
bit dig a bit deeper there are several
benefits for advertisers of YouTube
Because of its sheer sites it gives you
as I said the largest audience reach yes
so with over 2 billion active users each
month it is a tremendous Network where
you can reach everywhere in the world
yeah so you have access to a huge
audience and you can reach a large
number of potential customers that
audience is also very diverse and it
spans all age groups genders and
Geographic locations everybody uses
YouTube yeah so not like Tick Tock where
maybe a younger gen generation YouTube
spends all age groups
so you can tailor your ads to specific
demographics and Target very specific
groups YouTube gives you a variety of AD
formats as we talked about earlier and I
will share that with you so that is a
big menu of sort of options that the
advertiser has
because of YouTube's size and it
Advanced targeting capabilities it is
also a very cost effective way of
advertising with a relative low cost per
impression or cost per click yes so
making it very cost effective and
another big benefit of using YouTube for
your targeted advertising is the high
engagement in user on the on YouTube
yeah YouTube users spend an average of
11 minutes per day on the platform that
indicates quite High engagement and they
have an incline to comment to like to
share the content yes so it's a big
opportunity for Brands to build a
relationship with their key audiences
so here are some more facts about
YouTube's targeting capabilities yes so
in YouTube you can reach 90 of online
audiences in the United States
yeah so YouTube is available in over 100
countries and it supports about 80
different languages now what does that
mean for your targeting yeah so it
allows you to reach users in basically
every geographical location from entire
countries to individual cities or even
zip codes
yeah so they allow you to reach users
based on their language preference so
you for instance you can Target people
who speak a specific language or who
have set their preferred language on the
on their YouTube account
so another interesting statistic that
over 70 percent of in-stream ads on the
YouTube platform are now delivered
programmatically
yeah which basically means there is a
growing Trend towards automated buying
and targeting of your YouTube ads
so all in all the targeting on YouTube
is a big benefit of using YouTube ads
so let's look at some more Benefits
YouTube advertising is very cost
effective but it is important to
carefully plan and execute your
campaigns to maximize your Effectiveness
it can be cost effective based on
various factors like your target
audience your advertising goals and your
budget yeah you're getting different
advertising formats so that can relate
to the cost and the benefits that you're
getting and the YouTube
advertising is typically based on a cost
per view which means you only pay when
someone interacts with your ads and the
average cost per view on YouTube ranges
from let's say ten dollar cents to
thirty dollar cents but again this can
be slightly different based on targeting
ad format and competition
so also use the analytics that you get
here to measure the effectiveness of
your campaign and to measure to to get
the ROI of the campaign that you're
using
now for me one of the big benefits of
using YouTube ads is the increased
engagement YouTube's High engagement and
targeting options makes it a very good
platform for marketeer to reach a large
audience and to build relationships with
the customers
yeah customers spend an average of 40
minutes per session to watch videos so
with over 2 billion monthly active users
yeah you have a huge audience available
that you can build their relationship
with and the good thing is YouTube
videos are very highly shareable so
users they share their videos they share
the ads and they want to share it with
their family and their friends through
social media and messaging messaging
apps
so there's lots of features on YouTube
like comments likes and subscriptions
which helps with this engagement and
helps building the um the the
relationship with your audience
YouTube's recommendation algorithm also
helps to promote videos to users who are
likely to be interested in them and that
increases the reach and that increases
the engagement with your marketing
campaign
so by leveraging YouTube's High
engagement High best targeting
capabilities you can build brand
awareness Drive traffic to your website
increase conversions at a lower cost
compared to traditional advertising
methods
yep and then finally and we talked about
that yeah it is all about the measurable
results that you get and through the
YouTube analytics you get powerful data
powerful insights to optimize your
advertising campaign and improve the
return on your investment on the
platform so you can get very detailed
data like clicks impress Impressions
conversions so you can really make
decisions on improving your campaign
based on the data that you get out of
the um out of the Google the YouTube
YouTube analytics yeah so you can also
track the performance of your
competitors and Benchmark their
performance against industry standards
and that can help you improve your
campaigns as well
so lots of benefits that you can get out
of YouTube ads and that's why it is such
a popular advertising platform because
Brands they really believe that YouTube
is probably one of the best channels for
advertising
okay now let's look at the different
types of YouTube ads there's quite a few
of them first of all it is important to
understand the term trueview ads so
trueview is a type of video ad formats
over by YouTube that allows users to
choose whether or not to watch an ad
and with trueview advertisers only pay
when a user chooses to watch the ads
so that can help that you only get
interested users engaging with your
content
trueview ads can be targeted like we
talked about earlier again yeah based on
demographics interest search history
Etc yeah so they can also be optimized
for specific marketing objectives like
Grant awareness consideration or action
yeah so that can help you achieve your
campaign goals so overall trueview ads
they are flexible effective yeah and
allows you to reach a large audience
while ensuring that you only pay for
engaged views
so the first type of ads are trueview
in-stream ads
trueview in stream ads are very popular
and effective for reaching a large
audience on YouTube and for driving
engagement and conversion
so they are a type of Truth you add that
appear before
during or after other videos on the
platform
yes so true few in-stream ads are
skippable video ads so you can skip them
after five seconds so they can be up to
three minutes long and again the user
has the option to skip them after five
seconds and advertisers only pay when a
user watches more than 30 seconds of the
ads or the entire ad if it's shorter
than 30 seconds
or engages with the ad by clicking on a
call to action or companion Banner
okay so those are these true few
skippable in-stream ads
we then have to True view Discovery ads
trueview Discovery ads are a type of
trueview ads yeah that appear in search
results on the YouTube home page and a
long related videos on the platform
yeah whether it's a desktop or whether
it's the mobile they are thumbnail
images with a headline and a description
that appears in the search results and
on the YouTube homepage
so when a user clicks on the add
thumbnail they are taken to the
advertisers video on YouTube
so they can also appear alongside
related videos on the platform and you
only pay when a user clicks on the ad
thumbnail to watch the video
so they are very common you see them a
lot on on YouTube yes so those are the
trueview discovery ads
next the bumper ads I love the bumper
ads they are very creative and a very
effective way for advertisers to make an
impact in just six seconds and reach a
large audience they are a type of video
ad format that are six seconds long
they're short snackable and memorable
they're non-skippable and play before
the video content that users have
selected to watch so they are really
good for advertisers to reach a large
audience quickly and effectively and
they're often used in conjunction with
other AD formats like trueview in stream
ads
they can be targeted to specific
audiences based on their demographics
their interest search history
Etc and advertisers only pay for
Impressions so they pay for instance for
every 1 000 times the bumper ad is shown
right the next one are the non-skippable
in-stream ads a very effective way for
advertisers to reach a captive audience
on YouTube and again to drive conversion
and drive engagement it's a type of
video ad that appear before during or
after videos on YouTube
yeah so they are non-skippable which
means that viewers are required to watch
the entire ad before they can continue
watching the video they selected they
can be up to 15 second long and they can
include a call to action which is very
important yeah so to encourage viewers
to engage with the advertisers brand or
products
and you pay only when the user watches
the ad to completion or the first sect
for 30 seconds if the ad is longer than
30 seconds
right and then you have the outstream
ads outstream ads are an ad type that
appears on Partner websites and mobile
apps but not on the YouTube platform
itself
yeah so they Those ads they often play
on the page rather than in a video
player which means they don't require
users to watch them to continue viewing
the content they have selected they can
just browse on on the page they're
designed to be mobile first and are only
available on mobile devices makes them a
great option for advertisers looking to
reach an increase in Mobile audience on
YouTube
yes so they can be up to 15 seconds long
and can be optimized for specific
marketing objectives like brand
awareness consideration or action so you
only pay when a user views the ad for at
least two seconds or interacts with it
in some way like tapping the ads to
expand it or clicking through the
advertiser's website
right and then there is the must-head
ads must had ads are a premium ad format
offered by YouTube and they appear at
the top of the YouTube homepage
yeah on desktop and mobile devices
they're typically reserved for large
Brands and designed to provide maximum
visibility on the platform
so they can be up to 30 seconds long and
can include a call to action doing to
encourage viewers to engage with the
brands so it's great for promoting new
products or Services great for building
brand awareness or driving traffic to
your website
so you can run a must-hat ad for a
single day or for a longer period of
time
depending on the goals of your campaign
and costs can vary depending on factors
like the time of the year targeting
options selected and the duration of the
campaign
and then finally there is the overlay
ads so overlay ads is very effective if
you want to drive traffic to a landing
page and to generate leads yeah for a
product or a service but sometimes they
can be seen as intrusive
so it's important to create ads that are
engaging and relevant yeah so they are
display ads that appear on top of a
YouTube video while that video is
playing
Those ads are transparent and can be
text or image based and they usually
appear as you see here at the lower 20
percent of the video player
to promote a product or a service or a
brand they can include a call to action
targeting specific audience so you can
run the overlay ad for a specific video
or for a group of videos in a particular
category or Channel
so cost for Defender for the brand
depends on factors like targeting
options selected duration of the
campaign and the competition for ad
inventory so as you can see a whole
library of ads available yes so
um that YouTube has and that you can use
yep so good let's move on let's look at
the YouTube targeting we'll talk a lot
about the YouTube targeting so let's
summarize this targeting on the next
slide
yes so first of all there is the
demographic targeting so you can Target
people by age by gender by income and by
children
yeah so there's the behavioral targeting
so you can Target viewers based on their
search history the watched videos or the
website app and activities
you can also remarket people so you can
advertise you know you can show ads to
people who have visited your website so
if you have a website and somebody
visited a particular product page and
then left your website then you can
Target him on YouTube with an ad for
that particular product maybe doing a
promotion you can look at Affinity
audiences so you can Target certain
interests and trades with specialized
audiences and you can look at similar
audiences so you have a particular
audience selected and then you can ask
Google can you sort of select a similar
audience with similar interests or
behaviors so very extensive targeting
options and it is one of the key
benefits that you get out of YouTube
advertising
good
now
now how then do I create a YouTube ad to
create a YouTube video ad you have to go
into Google ads yeah so you must have an
account on Google ads you just click
sign in
and that will take you to your standard
dashboard for your all your activities
in Google ads
and you will find out you will see that
Google you or just YouTube ads is just a
particular section of the Google ads so
what we're going to do we're going to
look at the create so we're going to
click on the create button and we're
going to create a campaign
and as you will probably know with
um Google ads there is goal guidance yes
so you Google will advise you on the
type of goals that you can set for your
campaign and based on the goal that you
specify Google will automatically select
the type of channels it has available
for the advertising
you can also decide to do campaign
creation without goals guidance yeah so
what I'm going to do I'm going to click
brand awareness and reach and here is
immediately you can select what type of
AD what type of campaign type you want
to run do you want to do a display ad or
do you want to do a video ads and
obviously since we're talking about
video ads on YouTube then you click here
on video
so you're going to do a video Reach
campaign
yeah you can do an ad sequence by
showing ads in a particular sequence to
individual shoe viewers yes so that can
be really good to show viewers a series
of ads following the customer buying
cycle for instance or you can look at
people reach people in audience in audio
while they're listening on YouTube with
audio based ads so we're going to go for
a video Reach campaign and then here you
see the type of ads that you want to do
do you want to do the bumper ads or
skippable in stream yeah or a mix
yes so or do you want to do
non-skippable share your entire message
with up to 15 seconds and remember these
are the ads that we talked about in the
ad overview
so we're going for Bumper skippable in
stream or a mix
yep and then we click continue
so here is the campaign name will do
your budget let's say we're going to
spend 100 pounds a day you'll then have
your start date I'll put that a bit
further out
let's say the first of August we're
going to end in two weeks or select a
date
required let's say we're going to end in
two weeks
yeah so there is a 6.67 daily budget so
let's bump that up
I can also say yeah the daily budget
yeah so I'm going to do a daily budget
of 100 pounds
yeah and then here I have the locations
yeah so no and I can be very specific
with my location I can even do a let's
say rg4 I can just Target by
zip code as well
yes so and I can make that as advanced
as possible here so here you can see a
map even so if I want RG yeah so I want
rg7 you see how the map expands yeah RG
I can do rg40
or rg9 yes so here I see how that kind
of develops and how you can be very
specific with the targeting for your ads
and here you see an estimate estimated
number of Impressions that you would get
you can pick a language you can do
content exclusions remember we talked
about it where advertisers were not
happy with the um the videos where their
ads were shown so here you can say
content exclusion
and then here in the ad group you're
going to specify your segmentation
that's where you're going to specify
your targeting now I'm not going to go
into the details here but again these
are all the topics that we've sort of
discussed in the presentation
yep and then here of course what you
need is your video ads so here you're
going to specify the link or you're
going to basically add the link of the
video on that you have uploaded on
YouTube of your ads because of course
your video needs to be on YouTube
yep so that is one yeah so you create
your ads on every video creation
platform
yep and then you upload that video ad on
YouTube and then you have the YouTube
link and that's where you paste the link
of the YouTube ads
if you don't have an ad then you can
just create one in a few steps yeah and
YouTube actually has a video ad Builder
that you can use now where you can just
use templates how cool is this yes so
now of course you need to be aware that
if you use any of these templates you're
not the only one who will be using those
templates so it'll make your campaign
slightly more generic yeah and maybe not
as unique as you would like but the fact
that it's in there is a big benefit yeah
if you need to create an ad from from
scratch but there's lots of other tools
that you can use to create your video
ads yeah so let's just go to YouTube
.com yeah and I will take a video let's
say from one of my clients so do
that this one how we made 2500 gets
happy yeah so I'm just gonna I guess I'm
just gonna take this link in my ads I'm
gonna paste the URL here
yep and then here you see how your ad is
going to be like yes so here is the
skippable you have your display URL and
your final URL when people click on it
remember that it's the same as with
Google advertising so you can use the
display advertise the display URL as
part of your promotion yeah so that
could be a solution
dot Co dot euk forward slash summer
campaign or something
yeah and then you can have your final
URL as well yeah and then you can add a
call to action in your ad yeah that can
be a headline and here you see how all
of that is going to sort of show on the
on the ad
yeah so
lots of ways of adding your ad here and
then you set a bit for your ads and then
you basically create the campaign and
you're advertising uh your YouTube ads
is ready to be executed when
um based on the timings that you've set
and that is honestly that's how simple
it is to advertise on YouTube just go
into Google ads pick an objective that
has video ads as their one of their
channels then go through the campaign
setting go through the ad group settings
select your targeting and then link it
to the ad that you've uploaded on
YouTube as the ad that you want to use
for this campaign or use the YouTube
Tool to create your video ads in YouTube
good so that summarizes how you create a
YouTube ads and now let's close today's
session with giving you a few tips and
tricks on using YouTube ads so first of
all
keep it short and engaging short simple
and engaging because YouTubers have a
short attention span
and make sure you bring your message
across in the first few seconds of your
ads
try to summarize your ad try to use
storytelling tell a story that moves
your audience that builds an emotional
connection
yeah so think about storytelling
Concepts like there's a hero and there
is an uh there's an enemy so there is a
victory there is
um yeah there's lots of ways that you
can build storytelling elements into
your uh your YouTube ads don't forget to
add a call to action to your ads because
it encourages viewers to either go for
instance to your website or to buy a
product or to sign up for an event or to
register for something yes so make sure
that you use a call to action in your
your videos and even mention that call
to action in your videos as well use the
right target
um yeah so Target a Right audience so
you add reach the Right audience because
that will give you the best return on
investment on your ads
optimize your ads for mobile that is a
very important tip yes of course because
many people and we're talking probably
about 70 plus view YouTube on their
mobile phones so the ads will be seen on
their mobile phones and very simple yeah
so if you use for instance text on your
ads
yeah on desktop it will be easily
readable but on mobile it may be
unreadable so when you make an ad always
test it on your mobile device as well
and test and check the user experience
that people will get
and then of course continuously test and
optimize your ads to improve their
effectiveness maybe the description of
your YouTube ad or the description or
the title of your YouTube ad or the
thumbnail of your YouTube ads or the
opening of your ads so there may be
different ways test and optimize to make
sure you get the best return on
investment of on your ads so that
concludes today's session yeah so what
you've learned is what is YouTube
advertising what are the benefits of
YouTube advertising we looked at the
different advertising formats that
YouTube has available for ads we then
looked at how do you actually create a
YouTube ads on the on Google ads and
then I closed with giving you some tips
and tricks and if you like the video
again don't forget to click the like
button if you want to join our Channel
don't forget to click on the Subscribe
button below but this is it it's a wrap
and I will see you at the next video
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here